this is a message from the government
[Music]
hello and welcome to that was the work
that was
a summary of all the brilliant
progressive things that have happened
this month
we thought about writing actual jokes
for this episode
but nothing will ever be funnier than
people who thought
this year would be better than 2020 it's
only a month old and if it was a baby an
ancient sparta
it would have been taken outside and
drowned by now
there is good news however what the
peaceful transition of power
no a new season of vikings is out on
january the 6th
fueled by the belief that the only way
to preserve democracy
is to stop election results from being
duly certified
protesters led by part-time shaman and
full-time [ __ ] jake angeli
storm the senate finally a right-wing
lunatic that the gay community can get
behind
tragically several people were killed in
the process
one casualty was seen carrying a don't
tread on me sign
before being promptly trodden on the
reaction of the liberal media was a
predictable mixture
of horror and ejaculation and with good
reason
it was now clear that donald trump had
become a personality cult
a problem solved by his successor joe
biden who has no personality
in all fairness president biden gave a
rousing inauguration speech
which inspired millions of people
especially those who were gullible
enough to believe it
having promised to bring unity he
delivered on day one
with an executive order that made sure
everyone can compete in women's sports
no matter how many dicks they may have
finally they've made women
sports interesting vladimir putin
or as i call him uncle vlad is furious
of this cultural appropriation
as russia has been including men in its
female athletics teams
for generations britain's premier fat
scarecrow impersonator and
part-time prime minister boris johnson
was asked about whether joe biden is
woke
and gave a typically eloquent answer do
you think
as some senior politicians in britain
seem to the president biden
is woke i've
i can't comment on that i've i i finance
vice president karma harris's claim to
fame
is that she imprisoned thousands of
black men for marijuana offenses
inconveniencing college kids everywhere
when asked about her own weed use she
was
full of regret have you ever smoked i
have
okay and i and i inhaled i didn't i did
it
her love of inhaling is something her
and president biden
have in common that was the choice of
the election
one candidate wanted to [ __ ] his
daughter the other
wanted to [ __ ] yours in the meantime
twitter ceo
and hipster fagin jack dorsey
banned the leader of the free world from
the platform the move was widely
celebrated by people who really should
know better
however twitter did decide to keep the
account
of well-known free speech activists the
chinese communist party
terrorist group lashkara taipa and the
guardian
although to be fair to the guardian
unlike the ccp
they would never sterilize women they
don't believe in the concept of gender
trillionaire lex luthor impersonator and
amazon founder jeff bezos
the new social media platform parlor the
non-fictional supervillain now controls
all the web servers in the world making
him the most powerful baldi since dr
evil in summary donald trump is now
being impeached for a
second time joe biden is delighted
as he can't remember the first time the
news
really excited chuck schumer make no
mistake
there will be a trial and when that
trial ends senators will have to decide
if they believe donald john trump
incited the erection nancy pelosi on the
other hand
was extremely disappointed and now
i sadly and with her heart broken
over what this means to our country of a
president who would cite
insurrection
of the article of impeachment here's
some behind the scenes footage of
speaker pelosi
oh god yes one benefit of the biden
victory
is that the era of woke comedy is
finally over
late night comedy shows unleashed a
satirical barrage
on the new administration you did it
you survived the last four years today
this country
showed the world that there is no my
pillow large enough to smother our
democracy
seriously anyone else feel like they
just lost 280 pounds
democracy prevails can't believe they
forgot to mention these orange
does anyone feel like they lost 280
pounds
yeah that's how we felt in britain when
you took james corden off our hands mate
in other news britain has now been
infected with an extra deadly
foreign strain of covert 19. people
complained immigrants like me were
taking up housing
now we're freeing it up let's hope for a
polish train
that would get the job done twice as
quickly
finally even i can get on the housing
ladder um
be trump bungalow in eastbourne here i
come anyway
the virus is now completely out of
control but don't worry
boris has a plan freshly circumcised
penis chris whittie
has finally succeeded in closing all the
schools
due to kobit 19. if this carries on
kids will have no idea how to spell
povid or indeed
count to 19. you thought children were
stupid now just wait till they grow up
and make this guy look intelligent
the only ones who've had it worse are
the parents who've suddenly been
confronted by the fact that their kids
are complete
felons turns out it isn't the teacher's
fault that lil humphrey
isn't achieving in school it's your [ __ ]
jeans
parents everywhere have realized they
don't love their children as much as
they thought they did
except of course boris johnson who's
never met his
how many children do you have prime
minister i
i i should we talk about brexit no it's
more boring than a zoom quiz with your
nan
what about the fact that the eu is
trying to block us
from getting the vaccine we paid for
what a surprise your bitter ex is
furious that you moved on and won't let
you spend christmas with your two little
vaccines i just want to see
oxford and pfizer they're only nine
months old man
in cultural news according to russell t
davies
only gay actors should play gay
characters kevin spacey was ahead of his
time
what about being even more progressive
should only pedo actors play pedo
characters
i told you kevin spacey was ahead of his
time
the casting process for gay roles is
going to be brilliant
hi i'm francis and i'm here to audition
for the part of
gay guy number three
excellent and that's how i got my job at
trigonometry
thank you for watching that was the work
that was for january 2021
on behalf of everyone at trigonometry
remember
to stay in your care home save lives and
most importantly of all
don't have any of the wrong opinions